today on stick to foot will we break
down the upcoming week of college
football we break down everything is
happening in the NFL if you're a
quarterback god bless you you're
probably hurt right now or you have a
kick-ass mustache a lot happening we
also have an amazing guest tonight
because it is Michigan Wisconsin week
for us we have Braylon Edwards the only
man who may hate Jim Harbaugh more than
me we get him on the show I'm looking
forward to talking to him we haven't yet
so we'll see what happens by the end of
the show it's gonna be a good time
Mello's here Connors here you can see us
on youtube go to Bleacher Report's
channel there's a playlist you can
subscribe to the stick to football
playlist fellas welcome to the show very
excited about today obviously again
Thursday night as we record this
tailgate tour kicks off I don't have to
work tomorrow I'm just gonna be
traveling the beers will be flowing soon
yeah it's it's good to have you guys
back as the man that was solo this week
I feel so much energy right now in this
room or this little box that were in but
a lot going on around the NFL I know
that you guys are very excited I want to
hear your take on a couple different
things one being Jalen Ramsey's name
being thrown around the league every
single team is involved in this trade
talk Daniel Jones is named Starlin for
week three it is time for danger Jones
and like Matt hinted that there's a lot
of quarterback injuries in the NFL right
now but let's start with the most
important thing at least what I think
Jalen Ramsey on the trade block arguably
the best corner in the NFL depending who
you talk to you where do you guys want
to see him play who do you think is the
most realistic let's and what is his
value right now here's he is Jeff's
corner in football he is the best corner
in football I'm so tired of this and not
to come at you guys
listen if people want to say us to find
Gilmore that's fine he can be second
Jalen Ramsey is the best corner in
football and I don't care how many years
you played in the NFL or what your
little resume says on your box on ESPN
when they put your dumb ass on TV he's
the best corner in football in green
stop this [ __ ] and I'm tired of people
saying that Jalen's a character problem
what has he done
how many duis does he have how many
times he beat up his girlfriend how many
kids has he hurt you know what Jalen
wants to win he was as a rookie crying
on the sidelines at Jacksonville because
they suck so bad stop telling me that
Jalen's a character problem
I didn't even know I was so mad about
this and so we start talking about it
I'm so over it because he's not a
character problem the dude just is tired
of Tom Coughlin's being 90 million years
old and not knowing how to build a
winning football team look at their
first-round draft picks Haven Brian come
on
they can't trap to save their [ __ ]
lives and now you have a good player and
you're running him out of town
congratulations Jacksonville can't wait
to see you in London am i up yeah you're
up I was just gonna say the Chiefs I'm
not asked fired up I did see a lot of
obviously everybody saw this stuff about
how Jalen Ramsey isn't that good anymore
he might not be the best corner I I'll
accept that argument even but he's still
a really damn good cornerback and I
think he's gonna help any team that he
goes to with that being said I would
obviously like to see him join the
Kansas City Chiefs but I don't want to
see them give up too much for him I I
just don't know how it's gonna work out
with the salary cap there that they have
giving up a first-round pick for him I
don't know it would take more than all
right for them because they're probably
going to be picking lower than 28 would
be my guess
so they would expect more in exchange
for him than just one first-round pick
so it would be great but I won't be
upset if he goes somewhere else and I
think there was a long list of teams
reported interested in him that
shouldn't surprise anyone when a player
of this talent you know kind of enters
the market but I think and I said this
on the midweek show the Eagles make a
lot of sense here they're kind of in
that win now approach they're an
aggressive team they could use some help
in the secondary of course the Chiefs in
the mix the Browns kind of rumored to be
in this to that friend that one yeah
that one's weird because you know the
Browns a lot of personalities in that
locker room I think what's interesting
me with the Browns is they've made a lot
of win now moves when I don't think they
have to be a win now team now if they
were going after Trent Williams or if
they were in the Laremy Tunsil
conversations I would understand that
after seeing that offensive line right I
don't know I know Denzel Ward has been
you know not as good these first two
games it's only two games nothing to
worry about yet with Denzel Ward so
maybe that's why they're in that
conversation but I mean I think the the
point stands and
buddy is at least calling about jail
rhymes and that speaks to how good he is
I want to throw a sleeper team out there
the Detroit Lions because I had heard
all day Thursday that they were a team
that had had inquired there was some
interest there so Detroit has the salary
cap space obviously to make something
like this happen so I think they are an
interesting team but like you guys said
every team in the NFL is making this
call so when you see the list of oh this
team called well of course they do well
are the 49ers are in play today actually
the one game that came out said they
weren't okay that's all but that means
they probably are right psychology I
would love to see him I mean Kansas
City's obvious Billy is another one
where I think be great to Seattle he'd
be a wonderful fit but they traded so
many assets for Jadeveon Clowney they
might not be willing to do another one
guys let's move on to Daniel Jones is
danger zone time but also it's Josh
Rosen time the Miami Dolphins Thursday
right before we started recording
announced he is going to replace Ryan
Fitzpatrick
I like that both teams are making this
move I don't understand why we waited
two weeks this reminds me of Bill
O'Brien not starting - Alan Watson until
halftime oh the first guy yes it's like
okay you eventually made the right
decision but why did it take so long to
do this let's start with Josh Rosen
because he was in that 2018 draft class
he was my number three quarterback he
was your number one I think for number
one for me and Connor's number one so
you don't liked him I think we all had
him as a first-round quarterback and did
you know I did you didn't and but he's
been handed a really shitty situation I
don't think there's any anything around
that the offensive lines that he's
played with Aron's it reminds me of
David Carr when he came out of Fresno
State went to the expansion Texans and
just got punched in the mouth over and
over again or a lot like to show Watson
if you watch the Texans now so Rosen not
being mobile I think is obviously a big
issue holding on the ball a little bit
too long with bad offensive lines I
don't know that we're even gonna get a
good eval of him if he plays the next
four 19 weeks I don't know how you can
evaluate a player with these skilled
position players and this offensive line
when it's a team that is so clearly
tanking I don't understand still the
methodology to trade a pick for this guy
and now you're just sacrificing him
basically right throwing him out there
like if you were gonna go all in you
should have done it week one so I don't
know
understand what you're doing now because
you're right you're not gonna get a good
evaluation of what he can do I guess
you'll just see how much of the offense
that he knows and he can pick up on
which should be a lot because no one is
questioning that part of his game oh
you're just gonna run him out there and
get him killed this year so I don't I
don't know what the Dolphins are doing I
we've seen other teams and other sports
do this like the Houston Astros
I guess we'll figure out does does this
have a place in the NFL
can we see teams tank and rebuild by
trading away your best players trying to
play a young quarterback we'll figure it
out because the Dolphins are all in on
doing it on the Browns tried and Connor
and I were at they in Monday night they
did beat the Jets but they did not look
good at doing it I think Miles Garrett
looked really good mhm
there were a lot of struggles out of
that field that I saw obviously they had
the cap space and that the capital to go
get guys like Jarvis Landry Odell
Beckham jr. Odell won that game for them
but I don't know that we've ever seen a
team effectively tank in the NFL yeah I
don't think so yet until someone makes
the playoffs while doing it I think for
Rosen my problem is I don't think I
don't want to sit here and make excuses
for him because I think there's been
evident struggles from him but it's
almost like he left a horrible situation
in Arizona and found the only worse
situation in the NFL now they traded
Laremy Tunsil
that's a huge issue for an offensive one
that already isn't good they didn't
spend the summer prepping him as the
starting quarterback you had the entire
summer to do so now you're throwing him
into the fire week 3 against a great
Dallas team a great Dallas defense I
don't really know what this does there's
no skill players there there's no
offensive line there they just traded
their best promising defensive player
and make it Fitzpatrick where they're
gonna be down 25 nothing before you can
even say the words Kellen Moore I just
think it's absolutely ridiculous when
you look at this like well I don't think
we'll ever really know what Josh Rosen
could have been in the right system for
him now I do think those systems were
limited because like you just said math
and mobility was always a concern he is
holding onto the ball at the end of the
day though odd this is not the right way
to assess what you have in him and it's
pretty evident that Miami will go into
next year's draft probably looking at
some of these quarterbacks we're gonna
talk about later in the show yeah top
five today durability durability was a
huge question to with this
then shoulders so I mean how many weeks
are we actually gonna see him because
yeah I mean he got crushed last year
yeah you're just gonna blitz the hell
out of him that's all I would do that's
all I would do well on the flip side of
that guys Daniel jones unseats Eli
Manning which I was frankly surprised
when this news broke because Eli seemed
to have an umbrella of the Maura family
protecting him keeping him on the field
it comes down no he's gonna sit Daniel
Jones is the starter headed into Tampa
Bay Tampa Bay week excuse me so I'm
excited about this I really liked Daniel
Jones
throughout the season then I felt like
he got overrated but when we were just
talk about daniel Jones tools I liked
him a lot I thought he had a great
senior Bowl week but at at a point in
the the whole draft process it flipped
and he went from this guy's being
overrated - wait wait now he's getting
underrated and I still don't believe he
was worth the top ten pick but we're
gonna get to see what he can do again on
a team that doesn't have a great
offensive line I don't even think it's
fair to only point at Eli Manning right
now and say this is the only problem for
the Giants their defense has been
absolutely atrocious but I will say good
on the Giants for getting the
first-round pick on the field in week
three because you need to see what you
have there yeah it's a lot like when Eli
was there with Kurt Warner and taking
his place I was actually pretty
surprised that we saw this move come so
early in the season I thought it would
be like week six before we saw Daniel
Jones I was not his biggest supporter I
think that all of our listeners probably
remember that I I lot would have liked
him in the second round but he was the
first quarterback taken overall but I'm
excited that we will get to see what he
can do hopefully he can get the ball to
say Quan some more because I got him on
my fantasy team and really when we're
talking about the Giants that's what I
want yeah there's two sides of this for
me one I'm excited for Daniel Jones I'm
excited that the Giants fans get what
they want they get to see him as a
starter tough task against Todd Bowles
Todd Bowles is not only a very good
defensive coordinator but he's very good
against young quarterbacks now tempo
doesn't have this loaded defense but I
think the signing a Shaq bear it's been
big for them they'll definitely be
coached up and ready for Daniel Jones
but it's exciting to hopefully see him
give this offense some life I think on
the other side of this this goes back to
what we've talked about with Dave
gentlemen
building or rebuilding this giant seam
and this is maybe ownership getting
involved and every time we talk about
team building on the show ownership
getting involved is always a bad thing
why did you keep you Manning SCAP number
on this season
look at how poor that defense has been
so far they're leaving the offense hung
out to dry some of that money could have
been used to go get even if you're not
gonna go up to the premier player like
CJ Mosley one of the pass rushers that
went to Green Bay or anyone like that
keeping Olivier Vernon even though they
got a good return for their offensive
line I think it's just very frustrating
team building where we're gonna see what
this team is like with Daniel Jones and
I think the lines been better and say
Quan is amazing but I think once again
they could have been further along in
the process if they didn't just give
this legacy treatment to Eli Manning for
way too long
yeah and I'll be saying you know they
had three first-round picks we'll see
what Daniel Jones looks like Dexter
Lawrence has been I think okay it's only
two weeks so I a baby's been really
struggling yep yes he's I believe he's
only I stopped one pass thrown his way I
think he's like they've like 13 or 14 or
something thrown his way look seriously
it's ridiculous so again it's you play
zone it's 2 weeks whatever things can
change but they have to get a return on
investment from that 2019 draft class or
it really doesn't matter what they're
doing and with say Quan and Nate's
holder and guys like that all right
quickly though guys injuries are the big
word right now with quarterbacks Cam
Newton is out this weekend
big been out for the year drew Brees is
gonna be out for a little bit Sam
carnold is at least some encouraging
news sounds like he's coming back since
he gave me his mono while I was in New
Jersey Monday night I appreciate taking
one for the team on that one Sammy but
the injuries are concerning and so like
the Panthers we can see Kyle Allen this
weekend I'm excited for that Kyle Allen
he gets Kyler Murray that's gonna be fun
a little rivalry there actually yeah
yeah Melo's guy Mason Rudolph is taking
the ball in Pittsburgh for the rest of
the year
teddy and taste someone be splitting it
up in New Orleans but man if you're a
quarterback right now it is not a safe
place to be and it once again I think
speaks to how important that number to
quarterback is for every team in the NFL
yeah and like you mentioned later we're
gonna break down the top five
quarterbacks these teams might be
looking pretty heavily at this draft
because even guys like Drew Brees Ben
Birger they're old and they might say
they want to come back but that team was
gonna have to deal with we have a
quarterback who is a very old veteran
quarterback coming off of an injury
that's not usually something you're
wanting to deal with if you're in an
organization so these teams looking at
these young quarterbacks they might
start to get some hungry eyes there and
really looking at what the draft has
it's like it's like six of footballs
reclamation weekend right now I'm
certain for Josh Rosen it's big return
Matt's got teddy mellows rootin for
Mason it's like these guys have finally
yeah and I mean we could see Lamar
Jackson against Pat mahomes I know I
mean not head to head obviously he's
they both play quarterback but I'm
excited for that game Arrowhead home
opener of the year and Lamar Jackson
comes into town he's like the second
hottest quarterback in the league right
now so what we'll get to see if he stays
a prince or not on this one it's blind
review time this segment sting that I
know there we're like five people that
love it so it's not going anywhere
mellow we have Titans at Jags Thursday
night take it away and I have
double-checked this the game is actually
in Jacksonville so we don't have to
worry about that mess up happening again
I'm like the Titans and I like what
they're doing I think that the Gardner
Minshew hype we're gonna see it wear off
because tonight I'm expecting two
interceptions from Gardner Minshew this
Titans defense just made him look like
the draft prospect I thought he was
they're doing a great job the Titans are
getting after the quarterback playing
great defense and they're putting
Mariota in position to succeed and
that's why we see him have a big game
here on Thursday night Derek Henry
obviously helping out much better
prospect than I thought he was gonna be
he's actually your table to produce on
offense I love what he's doing and to be
able to see AJ Brown have the game that
he had last night was absolutely amazing
yeah I will say I thought Tennessee did
a great job really setting themselves up
as maybe the team to beat in the AFC
South this my kraebel defense is just
nasty and I know it's against
Jacksonville but being able to shut down
Leonard fournette and really go against
a pretty good offensive line and again
to your point Melo Derrick Henry
continues to make me look like an idiot
because I did not think this guy had
what it took to be an NFL starting
running
back this system is so perfect for him
he's showing the deep speed where last
time those T teams played he went for 99
yards we saw it again last night with
more big plays from Derek Henry yeah
Derek Henry finding the endzone for the
third week in a row to start off this
NFL season one final note though from me
guys as we recap this game you know tip
of the cap to Jalen Ramsey for playing
all out and what he basically knew was
his last NFL game in a Jacksonville
Jaguars uniform very interesting to see
him run off the field after that game we
will be in Madison Wisconsin this week
we're actually enroute as you're
listening to this don't forget Jordans
big tin pub it's a historic bar on
Regent Street they hold 16 a hundred
people in their beer garden it's the
biggest I think in the world I'm going
trump on this place it's big it's huge
my friends a category 5 nobody's like 45
have you heard this before it's a
category no one's ever heard of it it's
gonna be great it might even hit Alabama
this pub is so big we are gonna be there
at eight o'clock recording the podcast
coming out with us we're taking as many
koozies as mice like little Pelican case
will hold will be given those out
there's gonna be cheese we're sampling
cheese you can have some get some get
cheese that's not a joke we're really
giving away cheese not money what else
I'm sure with cheese yeah I don't
brought beer there's me a lot of fun so
come out we'll be doing the show live
you can hang out with us and then we'll
be there for a while after it but let's
get into this week's previews and pics I
am struggling at 11 and 9 Melo is at 13
and 7 Connor is at 6 in force and none
of us can really talk any [ __ ] because
we're not doing that great let's be
honest we're not doing that bad though
we're not my real life gambling is going
very very well this segment yeah so so
I'm actually bad even now so I'm feeling
very good about that all right
number 10 Utah -4 at USC the over-under
on this one's 52 and a half that feels
high to me given that we've seen now USC
a back-to-back weeks look a little a
bipolar offensively and Utah has such a
great defense our guy Zach Moss is just
gonna run the rock in this one I'm
taking Utah to cover and I would
actually take the under on this one I
agree with you I hate when that happens
but I agree the negative for on Utah I
think that they're gonna cover that
pretty easily but I don't expect a lot
of points here
Utah defense is salty I think that USC
is gonna give them a real true test
because they're gonna spread the ball
out they'll try to get things done in
the running game but you saw what BYU
did and they just said okay you want to
do this air raid offense no you're going
to have to run the ball on us and Utah
has the defensive line they have the
secondary they can shut down anything
you want to throw at them so I'm gonna
go Utah and I think they cover the
spread I and I'm gonna take the under as
well yeah I'm with you guys I mean
there's just no science to this one it's
pretty obvious that Utah's a strong
veteran defense Julian Blackmun and
started out the season a couple
turnovers already so really exciting to
see that for him as he went back for a
senior year
Utah should cover that line I'm actually
thinking about putting some real money
on this one not positive yet yeah I am
I'm not betting this weekend I say that
every weekend then I end up betting all
right number eight Auburn at number 17
Texas A&M this is one of the big games
of the week to top 20 teams Am is
favored in this one - three and a half
which surprised the hell out of me the
over/under set at forty seven and a half
so a little bit of offense expected I
was down on awkward - start the I really
was I thought just all watching that
offensive line last year they were
terrible but this defensive line is so
good remember back to week one when they
smacked Oregon in that comeback win I'm
actually gonna take all burn on this one
now I don't know about the spread I do
think it'll be close I can see it being
a 3-point game but it being in a em I
mean that's worth three points right
there but I do think all burn wins and
that's where you're wrong
because I think a and it was gonna win
this one app at Texas A&M no matter what
you feel about it that's a hard place to
play they pump in so much sound there
that it gets so loud that it is a very
difficult place to play and that's why
I'm going am here then another reason
for that is because I'm not sold on bone
Nicks I think that's a great story his
dad went to Auburn
he's been so inconsistent I know that
everybody wants to talk about him in his
first game he's a freshman starter at
Oregon they win that game he played like
[ __ ] he through multiple
interceptions he almost lost that game
for them he did nothing for me
I think this is gonna be a low-scoring
game actually so I'm gonna take the
under I think a and M can get it done
they stopped the run against Clemson
with
Travis etn I don't think the Auburn can
get the run game going against A&M and I
think that Kellerman can score more
points here so I'm going to take am who
is the favorite in Las Vegas three and a
half points but the lower ranked team so
that's not really an underdog I guess
but I am gonna take am ya in the real
life gambling world this is a game where
you look at and you say hell no not
touching this game
I took urban because I think they can
cover that three and a half line but I
don't feel great about them and this one
for the reason you just said Melo are we
really getting excited right now over
beau Nicks I think it's more of a story
than Talent I do like Auburn's defensive
line a lot I think Derek Brown up front
is is obviously the dude to watch but I
mean this is a game where A&M you gotta
kind of win this one you need a big win
at some point this is their chance to
get one it is definitely a chance here
is one that I got to find a way to watch
this Oklahoma State at number 12 Texas
Texas is favored by five and a half the
over/under is it 72 and a half I'm gonna
take the over on this one it's amazing I
think Texas wins I do think they cover
but I'll say this
and I'm right writing about him it comes
out Friday mornings to check it out my
scouting notebook I love Hubbard from
Oklahoma State's running back Chu
Hubbard that dude is a stud and I don't
know if Texas can stop him because they
really can't stop anyone I will say I
think the Texas offense has looked
better this is a 6:30 game DKR should be
rockin and we know that Texas can score
points a Mellinger almost a thousand
yards passing 11 TDs he's been more
effective on the ground game as well I
think people are bought in a little bit
more but can Texas stop Spencer Sanders
can they stop Chuba Hubbard can they
stop Thailand Wallace I don't know I
think you looked at my notes like do you
see what I have highlighted as my first
no I've read about it today before I
even - uh-huh
whatever Ghost Rider mellow here I'm
just gonna turn my screen Matt can't
cheat off of me anymore okay let's go
Oklahoma state scares me they really do
because there's such a high-powered
offense in this Texas defense sucks they
have nobody that can cover in the
secondary cadence turns does not look
like the same cadence turns exactly
whatever that means
they make me very nervous and I have no
idea how Texas
is gonna stop tuba Hubbert he's very
good catching the ball out of the
backfield and he's run for 200 yards I
think twice this season already throwing
Spencer Sanders at quarterback this
everything is just leading up for an
upset I don't like the way it feels I
would not bet any money on this game
because Texas is the five and a half
point favorite I think Texas can get it
done but man I'm nervous about it as a
Texas fan and if I were a better I would
stay away from this game very nervous
but I am gonna say Texas where we're in
Stillwater I would be even Oh verified
once again Stillwater I better and
Oklahoma flight I was gonna ask you guys
hasn't Texas lost the Oklahoma State on
their own field five times in a row now
it's been a bad I don't know about five
in a row but it's yeah you're right I
know it's really bad I went back and
forth on this game the entire day in
terms of the spread
I think Oklahoma State covers I actually
am gonna pick them to win this game I'm
sorry guys
the guy for me is Thailand Wallace I
know they haven't played anyone yet and
even when they have they've actually
been you know they the defense has given
up their points I think sammelan gur is
probably gonna have his way in this one
I just think Thailand Wallace can have a
hundred and fifty yard kind of day
receiving against this Texas secondary
then being on the road even though
they've won at Texas a lot makes this
one tough but I really liked the upset
in this game just because it's a
mismatch kind of opportunity and I've
actually seen the the line on this
depending on where you look you guys get
five you can get a five and a half or
you can get it at six so it's kind of
all over the place writers you can find
it for nine and a half what that I'm not
spread Texas - nine and a half I would
put it on Oklahoma State right you know
there's no way that Texas beats them by
10 points text our guy in Vegas yep
right right look I mean almost everybody
is five and a half six there are people
out there that have it at nine and a
half and if you can find it - you can go
online that's out there I would put
money on it that way because Texas might
win they're not gonna win by double
digits all right number seven Notre Dame
at number three Georgia probably the
biggest game of the week Georgia the
host favored by 14 and a half points the
over-under at 57 and a half and boys I
am all over Georgia this game though I
think is a good scouting matchup we get
to see
Thomas against Julia no croire we could
see Jake Fromm against a pretty good
Notre Dame defense DeAndre swift against
a similar Curt not a similar crew the
same crew so I'm excited for that
matchup in this one just some good
old-fashioned Saturday scouting when it
comes to this game but I think Notre
Dame loses ugly yeah I could not believe
the line on this one 14 and a half I did
not expect that obviously I thought it
would be closer to like six and a half
but I do think Georgia wins and I do
think Georgia wins pretty easily I don't
know that I would bet against the spread
on this one but I will take the Georgia
Bulldogs to win that is a fat line I
think you know when you look at the
games of the week you probably go to
this one and say I'll take Georgian it
covered by at least a touchdown but more
than two it's rough I'm picking Georgia
to win don't love that number that's a
lot to cover although wouldn't shock me
if they actually blow out a top 10 team
on their own field yeah absolutely not
all right the game we will be at fellas
number 11 Michigan at number 13
Wisconsin they're gonna be jumping
around
Wisconsin's favored in this one - three
and a half would stay home field
advantage the over/under is 44 and a
half the lowest that we've seen this
week in the top five games and if you
see me Saturday I'm gonna be wearing
this sweet-ass retro Wisconsin t-shirt
because I'm rolling with our guy jtt in
the Badgers I don't think Michigan can
stop him Wisconsin coming off a bye yeah
I know Michigan is - but Jonathan Taylor
we've seen limited touches from him so
far this year I think they're getting
him ready they were saving him for this
week when he's gonna break out with one
of those classic 250 yard games that
we've seen from him over the course of
his brilliant career already 4,000 yards
rushing in college and he's just gonna
add to that this week only 35 carries
headed into this game yeah and our guy
Adam Kramer says that he wants to hit
that record he wants to break it he's
after rate Ron Dayne this is his chance
and I think this is really his chance to
get on the Heisman hype I think he
should be up there he's one of the best
running backs in the country this is his
opportunity if he can go for 250 plus
which I definitely think he can against
this Michigan defense then we'll have to
talk about him as a Heisman candidate
it's a true Heisman candidate I'm going
to Wisconsin as well I just don't see
how Michigan can compete they struggled
with Middle Tennessee State and they
struggled with army because they
couldn't stop
run now you have to face one of the
toughest run offenses in the entire
nation in Wisconsin I think Wisconsin
controls the clock I think it's gonna be
close now but I definitely think
Wisconsin wins this game yeah you're
asking Shea Patterson to go on the road
a really really tough place to play and
kind of carry that offense I don't love
it I don't love that at all Wisconsin
all the way for me
I think they've surprisingly gotten good
play out of their quarterback Jack Cohen
from New York this year already he
hasn't turned the ball over in the air
and just JT go of your Heisman moment go
beat Michigan and man this is a game for
Jim Harbaugh got to have this one got to
have this one but I don't think it
happens I think Wisconsin wins yeah I
think so too mellow you have your
underdog this is our super underdog
locksmith game of the week to bet your
money on because I don't have the nuts
to bet my own money on I'm going with
Northwestern they are playing they host
Michigan State Michigan State cannot
score points northwestern likes to stop
people from scoring points this is gonna
be a very low-scoring game in the spread
at six and a half there might not be
anybody that scores six and a half this
might be like a three to six game I'm
putting my money on northwestern here
because I don't think Michigan State can
score double digits against this defense
I think it's gonna be very low-scoring
Michigan State probably pulls off the
wind but I would not be surprised if
we're looking at a very low-scoring game
like a 10 to 13 type win I'm telling you
put your money on Northwestern this week
all right fellows it is a great time to
update our big boards when it comes to
the quarterback position it's been a lot
of talk about who should the Miami
Dolphins get if you're a Titans fan if
you're a Buccaneers fan who should you
be looking at maybe you're a Chargers
fan you're worried about Philip Rivers
or the Saints and Teddy Bridgewater's on
a one-year deal this is has been billed
a very good quarterback draft I'm gonna
tell you I don't know that it will be
and that's why I'm gonna start at number
five on my list I'll give you my 5 then
mellow than Connor did we didn't talk
about that the break that's how we're
gonna do it number 5 on my list and a
guy who's really rising up the board for
me is Joe burrow I would not be
surprised if by April Joe has worked his
way into the first round conversation he
is a great leader he's a great character
guy athletically it's there mechanically
it's there we just haven't seen a huge
sample size but every week when he plays
he can
in use to impress now I will say and
I'll take a shot at my own team he has
not played a good defense yet we need to
see him play Alabama we need to see him
play Auburn need to see him play the
Georgia's of the world to see what he
can do in those situations but I'm very
encouraged and intrigued by Joe borough
number four on my list is where I have
Jake Fromm I was telling Connor before
we recorded today Jake Fromm to me is a
lot how I felt about Andy Dalton it's
how I felt about Garrett Stidham the
guy's just a good football player but
he's not gonna blow you away with any
types of tools or you know he's he's not
big he doesn't have a strong arm he's
not fast he's just a good quarterback
now that's gonna work for some people
and not others so I think when we talk
about Jake Fromm he's gonna be good for
some teams not everyone so that's
important to remember number three on my
list this is where I have Jordan love
from Utah State
I love his traits he makes some amazing
throws that not many people can make he
also makes some very bad throw Sonny
look at the Wake Forest game where he
had multiple picks where you're just
like brother throw it away he has some
learning to do but a lot like how I felt
about Josh Allen back in the day he is
not surrounded by what you would call
Pro prospects at the wide receiver
running back or offensive line positions
so he is not working with a cast of
characters like everyone else on this
list but I'm very intrigued by the
traits that we get from Jordan love
number two and I am not sold on this at
all he could be number six on my list in
a couple weeks
Justin Herbert I know he looks the part
but god I get Blaine Gabbert feels when
I watch him play like I get yes
guarantee watching him he is I mean he's
big he's tall he's athletic
he just doesn't come across as very
tough to me there's not a lot of moxie
there the Auburn game especially I
really felt like he kind of folded down
the stretch I just don't I don't believe
in Justin Herbert but the physical
traits are absolutely what we're looking
for if you could build a quarterback
they would probably have a lot of Justin
Herbert's traits more than anyone else
on this list and a number one for me
with a bullet really is to uh I know
there have been doubters out there who
uh too is not tall enough he's two
inches taller from maybe three then the
guy who was just drafted number one
overall people say he's a lefty so was
Steve Young so was Michael Vick I really
don't care that he's left-handed I don't
think it's that big of a deal he is
accurate and I don't know if it's
because he's at Alabama and we're tired
of them being good the people can't
appreciate the Tewa is just good at
football he's accurate he's a good
leader he's a good kid he's good athlete
he's everything you should want in a
franchise quarterback so tua is tops on
my list
yeah and I'll dive in right here with my
number five I'm going with Jordan love
and he is at five because at times
you'll watch him even like I watched his
Michigan State Till tape last year I
watched even its wait for us this year
and it's like holy [ __ ] some of the
throws that he makes no one else can
make and then some of the throws he
makes no one else would even try that
because no one else [ __ ] and it's triple
coverage it's just not make me sit lock
yeah I mean there's a lot of talent
there and he has I mean he's at Utah
State so maybe the coaching hasn't been
great but I do want to see what he can
do I'm intrigued by him I'm not in love
with him like you said with this
quarterback class I don't love it I
actually I don't think it's as great as
we all thought it was going to be I do
think there's one quarterback at the top
and then there's some other guys that
will maybe even be fighting like a mid
first-round pick number four for me I am
going with Jacob Eason I still haven't
got to watch a lot of his game there's
just some the Washington games or like
10:30 at night here so it's hard to do I
have to try to record it and watch it on
Sunday mornings so I haven't seen a lot
but what I have seen so far I am
impressed with but I do need to see him
do it against some good quality defenses
because he's been a little bit
inconsistent too so I wanted to take
another look at him number three would
probably wear like a different tier of
quarterback I like Jake from and I he
doesn't Wow me but I think a lot of that
is the offense he's not asked to do a
lot besides hey turn around and hand it
to one of our four running backs who are
gonna rush for a hundred yards if we
just keep doing this we're going to win
games and that's what Kirby Smart does
take care of the ball we'll run the ball
we will win games so I like Jake from
and I think that he does make a lot of
really good throws with touch with arm
strength he just he's not asked to do a
lot so a lot of people are down on him
and the same concerns with Justin
Herbert is you had I don't know what
quarterback he really is at times he
doesn't seem like he's ready to lead a
team and be the face of a franchise and
the Blaine Gabbert comment I think
absolutely perfect he really reminds me
of a Blaine Gabbert type quarterback but
he's tall he has a strong arm he asked
he's athletic so he's gonna be up there
for everybody on draft boards and then
the number one guy who I do think is
head and shoulders above now is to him
coming out healthy I was very low on him
and even at the start of the season I
did not have him as my QB 1 but him
being healthy with his legs under him
showing some arm strength this year the
touch and the accuracy was always there
but being able to show some arm strength
he looks absolutely amazing and I wanted
to credit a lot of his receivers for
what they're able to do but he does a
very good job of getting them the ball
and getting it to them in stride so we
can see a Henry rugs and you know jerry
judy take off and do what they can do I
really like to and I think he is
probably going to be the first if not
second picking this draft yeah you look
at this draft class guys and I know 2018
we were all over the place how we felt
about those top five quarterbacks and we
all had different rankings last year a
lot of the same thoughts this year it
feels like it's gonna be the same all
three of us have to a write at the top I
think that's undisputed but I'll start
right at five here I do have Joe burrow
at five I really liked the steps Joe
burrow has taken I think he looks like a
different player in this offense I think
he's moved and really well in and out of
the pocket I think his feeling the
pockets very good so I still think he's
a day-to player right now but he's gonna
be looking to make that jump to sneak
into round one Jacob Eason at four from
me like Melo the arm talent is just
tremendous and yeah he hasn't been
perfect this year especially against Cal
I believe was the game where he
struggled a little bit but the throws he
can make at a great size for a
quarterback but just the arm strength he
has a legit top-tier NFL arm it's
everything else that he'll have to work
on right now we need to see more of him
we didn't see the guy play last year as
he was a transfer so a wait-and-see on
Eason but I like the promise
jake Fromme at 3 I just think he's very
smart he does everything all the little
things that leads you to wins I don't
think he's gonna be a top 5 kind of pick
because I don't think he's physically
overwhelming and then Justin Herbert at
2 is the one that we all have met too
but we all feel the same way about him
he can make somebody look very very bad
if he ends up being a top 2
pick which I think he will I think
somebody's gonna roll the dice on him
and maybe he'll make someone look very
very smart we don't know you that yeah
there's a lot left to dissect with
Justin Herbert but I know he's number
one for a lot of people I think it's
safe to say this show feels the same way
where there's a gap between him and twoa
right now and I don't think it's close I
feel very good putting my name behind
twoa just like I did with Kyler last
year I think with to adjust the accuracy
once again the feel in and out of the
pocket the athleticism I don't have
concerns about the height but the way he
can tear you up in the intermediate
passing game really all three levels of
the field is very very special he just
needs to stay healthy so this
quarterback class there's a clear guy at
the top and a lot of question marks
underneath that we're excited to watch
shakeout one thing I'll say guys before
we go to break and bring in Braylon
Edwards none of us have Jalen Hertz in
the top five yeah he impresses me more
every week I'm so excited to get to see
him in a couple weeks in Dallas when we
were there for the Texas to--you game
because yeah I mean he just looks better
every week so if I could say there's a
guy that's not on my list that could be
very soon it's probably gonna be Jalen
Hertz all right boys let's take a break
we come back former Michigan superstar
the number three pick by the Cleveland
Browns former two and former 49er take
that Braylon edwards we are joined by a
player I should loved we're the same age
so as I was coming up through high
school in college I was watching him
every Saturday Braylon Edwards who was a
stud at Michigan was the number three
pick in the draft
I was not picked in the draft you were
though Brennan thanks for joining us man
first question I want to ask you though
I want to jump right into this because
it's like hot in the news right now you
were quoted as saying Michigan is
light-years behind Ohio State do you
feel that way still do you want to like
backtrack it or you just want to like
keep pushing that envelope I'm not back
to anything I say I said what I said I
meant not standby the reason why the
comment came about is one you know were
14 and one last 15 games you know also
how stay every year is a team that is on
the verge of going to the Final Four or
having a team that could possibly go all
the
we all know they have not been and are
not what I mean but like yours behind
let me break it down is it's not a hard
ball thing this is a Michigan since
Lloyd less thing this is a identity
thing when you look at the team's
let's just stay with Ohio State we have
to go to Oklahoma Clemson Georgia
Alabama let's just look at how state
what they do is they stay consistent to
their identity they're going to get guys
up front to get push that extreme
extremely challenged athlete their
cornerback their secondary usually it's
going to be a top three four five in the
country each year but that's not it
because Michigan has been able to
compete defensively over the years
you've had a lot of really good players
you look at from Jake Ryan and Frank
Clark all the way till now Rashard Gary
Devon Bush in the league currently it's
the offensive side of the ball when you
look at the teams that have the success
the Clemson instantly you think of the
shower Watson you think of Trevor Lauren
and she thinking back Eddie now he took
the to our receivers they have now digs
another kid you think Alabama you think
of Jalen Hurd's you think of Simms
running like they had before you think
quarterbacks that were up for the
Heisman you think running backs that
have won the Heisman you think Oklahoma
two quarterbacks to the won the Heisman
one that possibly is going to win the
Heisman you think every team that has
had success in that final four
championship level has had a quarterback
that was either up for the Heisman or
was first team all-conference or was up
for the Maxwell Award you have a running
back that is arguably up for the dope or
arguably up for or won the Heisman and
you have stud wide receivers at some
point that's been Michigan's achillea
killings Hill for the past 14 years is
they don't have those players on offense
and that's what I mean by light-years
behind in order they keep asking this
question is this going to be the year
that Michigan does it they haven't done
it yet they haven't come close to doing
here and it's because of the offensive
side of the ball every year for the last
12 years Michigan has been asking the
same question who's on a quarterback
like every year last year Shay Patterson
had a statistically not too bad of a
year comes back
this year for its fifth year what's the
question is it going to be Shane is it
Dylan McCaffrey is it Joe milk who's
gonna be the running back name the last
time Michigan's had a stud stud officer
player I'll tell you when it was denial
Robinson in 2012 yeah that's seven years
ago
if seven years ago Devin Funchess was
really good
I didn't like the move to wide receiver
in high school eight on college think he
should stay to try then it would have
been better but to each his own outside
of those two you've had some pretty
decent players karana Hagan was a decent
running back or Mars or on JD chess and
I'm pretty decent receivers but you
don't have those guys that you're
looking at before like yeah this guy's
gonna win the blizzard off this guy is
gonna be up for the dope and that's what
I mean by light-years behind every year
Ohio State is gonna have a JK darling
Ezekiel Elliott a Carlos hi JT berry
justin fields Haskins
Benjamin Victor let's go load the
Braxton Miller the list goes on that's
the difference I think in the play we're
getting great defense we have people
that want to go to our to Michigan the
brand is back we're beating the teams we
should be beating for the most part it's
the switch on often we don't have the
consistent or for that matter the any
players that explosive and gang
takeovers so brilliantly I mean about
light-years behind do you think that Jim
Harbaugh is the guy that can bring this
program back that can have the offense
that can compete with Ohio State so that
they're not light years behind you know
what it is it I don't know I whoever can
get the recruiting because I obviously
have something to recruit obviously
there's a there's a there's a glitch in
getting that 4 star 5 star and a lot of
it is not Jamar as well Jim Harbaugh is
far to that question a lot of guys that
are four and five stars just don't want
to come up north they don't want to go
to Maryland they don't want to go to
Penn State they don't Penn State have
that really good run but on average ten
states not like that they don't want to
come to real Illinois Wisconsin
Northwestern like Northwestern and
Wisconsin those schools they're making
good records with what they have they're
finding a way to win these 10 and 11
games but no one wants to come up here
for some reason
Ohio State seems to be the only place
where Georgia Texas
Atlanta's Tennessee Georgia Texas
Florida where those guys want to come up
north to take a chance
Ohio State seems to be the only school
so with that being said I don't know if
he fired Jim Harbaugh bring in somebody
else
let's say Jim Leonard defensive
coordinator Wisconsin and he has the
same issues and getting those kids from
the south they seem to be wanting to
stay in Sec ACC tax well country so some
it might seem crazy to talk about
Harbaugh potentially on the hot seat but
do you think another loss through Ohio
State this year if that happened that
conversation starts around him people
have already started to say that because
you know he can't be a high state and
they're starting to look at what I said
last year and year before now starting
to perform just are going to look at the
games we should have won and lost so now
you add that into the pot so ok for loss
of the house state but then you make the
excuse what everybody's had some great
teams okay loss to Iowa in 2016 when
they should've won when this was their
chance to go to the Final Four you move
the South Carolina in the ball game with
South Carolina not a good football team
at all that you let them come back and
beat you you know you lose the Michigan
State in the monsoon so not so much the
loss it's the fact that you do five
interceptions in a monsoon which means
you let the quarterback throw five
instructions in the monsoon you look at
the house they lost last year you look
at the Florida loss in the ball game
last year all these things are starting
to get stirred in the pot now on the
flip side of that he has changed a brand
of football he is getting on average
nine and a half winter season he's won
in nine or ten games a season he's
getting the recruiting there he's got
the Michigan brand back in the public
spotlight and be in the good way in the
positive way but he just hasn't gotten
over that hump so if he loses this year
doesn't get over the hump do you allow
him another chance
because he is winning ten games or do
you put the pressure off you know Mike
Gundy has a great program going on down
there in Oklahoma State they're going to
win 8 games a year sometimes 10 I think
he has 14 win seasons in his 11 year
tenure there or something like that
they're gonna challenge they're
consistently beating up on the Texas
they're consistently beating up on Texas
each year
although Texas just got back decent but
they're not gonna go to the Final Four
they're typically not going to win the
big 12 they're typically not going to
win a national championship so do you
want to Oklahoma program
Oklahoma State program or do you want to
be like Oklahoma no I think that's that
is a great point and we should point out
you have a book that came out a couple
days ago it's called doing it my way my
outspoken life as a Michigan Wolverine
NFL receiver and beyond outspoken yeah
kind of a feud with your school I don't
write not with a school but with the
media department with Jim Harbaugh would
you call it a feud it is this
understanding and was last year last
year I tweeted out during the Notre Dame
game and I was a little harsh and a
little over passion and low over
frustrated and a little over you holding
right yeah hold on I was with the lumps
I mean not this it's anyway that's what
you do on Saturday you watch football
and you you indoors but we rather love
this event and we had fun we were you
know engaging conversation and it's kind
of like the Godfather sound like that
scene in The Godfather where the
families are meeting and in the middle
of the meeting Sonny gets ready to say
something and Vito pulls them back and
at the end of the beating Beatles Act
certainly what's wrong with you you
never let anybody outside the family
know what you think and that's what I
did well
I was very over aggressive and I let the
world know what the family was thinking
so there was a lot of people in that a
lot of people know that felt the same
way I did however they didn't say and I
would never say who was but they didn't
say anything they didn't go there
Twitter they didn't go on the radio and
I did I went the next step that you
never take so I wish I could take that
back and I was especially talking about
the kids in and directly I specifically
the kids however what I said came to
life they almost lost Northwestern she
lost Northwestern
they did lose two house a very
embarrassing manner they did lose to
Florida another embarrassing manner they
come back this shitty almost rooster
army so a lot of things that I did point
out we're true you just don't say it in
that matter
so that's what I would like to take back
alright so one other thing that you kind
of had a feud with over Michigan is the
jersey number you tried to start a thing
with the jersey number one really it was
it was kind of in place before you got
there you wanted to really take it and
make it a thing and then rich rod kind
of kind of stepped on that and ruined it
and then I have to see guys out there
like Shea Patterson we're number two for
Michigan which absolutely just there are
three people wearing two for the one as
a kicker it pisses me off
we're how do you feel about this now
with like jersey number one being worn
by a defensive back and sometimes a
freshman and jersey number two being
worn by hell it seems like anybody now
see and that's why I was able to write
the book and I'm glad I was able to us
to clarify some things because I never
had a few with Michigan over the number
one Jersey because the scholarship
endowment was never for the specific
number one the scholarship endowment we
just called it the number one endowment
because that was our number one it was
very important to me so we called it
that but at the end of the day you can
give the Jerry's wherever you want to as
long as it but it should have been a Y
receipt and that was the dessert history
I mean we'll 5050 with us with us you
get fifty five to a kicker yeah right
Oklahoma give I think it's 68 Texas what
Texas against 68 or whatever it was to
it but anyway my thing was it should be
Y receiver and then they should be very
understanding of the pressure that comes
with that like I even though I was
probably the only one had to earn it
after I did I kind of set a new
precedent it was you know you got to
earn it I came in with eighty I worked
my tail off I did everything I was asked
to do to get one and then when I
finished I had all the records I had
friendship I had learned to be a leader
I had learned to be a teammate I learned
Oh No so it you know that's what I
learned so I wanted to be that way
rich rock comes in and wants to give it
to a DB as bargaining chip
you know Brady was always good about it
he gave without once together with the
Funches but I was at the front except
played well and had won nine other
numbers and rich variety and uh jump
even Jim came to me his first year when
he was gonna give it out he said hey I
got three guys that are competing and
camp and this was 2015 so I got three
guys that are competing account what do
you think about whoever wins I'll let
them wear the number and I told him I
said it shouldn't be about fighting to
wear the numbers it should be someone
that you think deserves I said but
you're the coach you know so I'm gonna
support you gave the number took a
Korell Crawford what is the core
Crawford end up doing he transferred so
now every Thomas is wearing a number
who's a pretty good defensive players a
lot of talent area in him seat up see a
future he was a good kick returner
actually had a touchdown less in the
Notre Dame game the game at that's which
we speak but if I'm me which I am I'm
just I'm giving them the number well I
think someone earns it or someone
deserves or someone understands it then
they can have it you know like sometimes
you don't have to be ass like an I think
that will be a cool thing like if you
sauce like someone have a career where
freshmen had a tremendous freshman
season and they're just doing everything
that you say you well you can have a
conversation with that kid yeah I don't
mind it's a quarterback you know hey I
think that you are you deserved where's
number one how would you feel about
wearing that or if the guy just asked
you or told you hey coach i'ma bust my
butt and I'ma prove that next year you
gonna let me wear number one right
things like that are deserve the numbers
just here here's the hitter it's
available and I'm Anna I'm like how LSU
is with 18 I gots an honor it's a big
deal it an accessory with it right habit
you can go down the list of all the
berrykins at 1:55 first-round draft
picks and setter start with junior say
let's go so you know that's how that's
why I stand there its history like I
just wish that the number was
appreciated more so that the person
wearing it would be a bit that would
would play at a higher level cuz you
can't and once you understand something
you can't under understand that you know
you know it is and you play from that
Brown counting both college and NFL
who's your favorite coach you ever
played for position coaches area
Campbell's okay it's my wide receiver
coach at Michigan he's now why receivers
especially our office coordinator for
the Bowling Green but I would say Rex I
would say Rex but there will be like a 1
a and B Rex because of my career how it
happened when I got there where we were
at cetera ly Rex was it was great
he let he let players be men he treated
men as men and they played the game like
men they stayed out of trouble
quotations for the most part they were
here a good fathers good husband
he came in did work put in work they put
the team first and we had and we had a
lot of fun with it one B would be if I
were drafted to the Seahawks when I was
young and I played for Pete Pete will be
my favorite coach Pete Carroll is
amazing coach he's amazing person to be
around but he loves kids
he loves young players and kids that's
why you'll see him revamp his team a lot
you pay attention to his track like his
trend he gets rid of guys as soon as
they hit that five-year mark like he's
looking to move him or four years or
that's when people start battling look
at old timers cam got hurt look at
Richard Sherman look at Sydney writers
you know city was her look at Golden
Tate but he loves you when you're young
and then he tries to bully because he
tries to keep her precious that you USC
model it worked the USC so I got to feel
like if I was drafted to Seattle when I
was younger with him I would have had a
lot of fun with him for five years
yeah exactly that's about as long as
Pete keeps you around you mentioned kids
and that that triggered something that I
want to ask you about hopefully you
watched the office or you won't get this
reference but you're like the original
Scots tots man that I don't know if
enough people know about this that you
donated $10,000 to a hundred kids in
Cleveland when you were drafted you gave
out a hundred scholarships not laptop
batteries actual scholarships to kids I
don't know how that doesn't get talked
about enough in an era where it seems
like too many players are in the news
for negative things I think it's I think
it's because the negativity overshadowed
it but at a high level I was talking to
my mom about Justin he's like I've
thought this forever but you know the
times did I say I had controversy or I
got myself in into some hot water let's
use that term were I got into the
incident outside the nightclub with
LeBron James's friend the incident isn't
a big incident it because you know four
guys tried to jump me obviously they
didn't win I know I fight I'm sorry I'm
sorry I grew up in Detroit but if that
incident carried no wait until the
article added LeBron James friends so if
you were look it looks like Braylon L
was on the brown guy threw a fight oh
wait let me read the whole article oh he
got into a fight with LeBron James
friends didn't they interview LeBron you
know that year so now you guys that like
that spray the networks in LeBron that's
national headline fast forward to the
DUI in New York it's one of the UI -
it's a DUI in New York of all cities the
media cat3
it's a DUI and you're after we want hard
knocks that year so the Jets were
definitely in the national spotlight
with the DUI and you had the whole Revis
holdout then you had Rex Ryan and his
wife and they're interesting interesting
interests then you had that was when the
reporter came out on Brett Favre and
said Brett Favre was sending
inappropriate pictures so all these
things were surrounding the Jets like
they just became beating
to talk about meteor wise so I got my
DUI fit right in there with that and it
was blown up so now when you do
something like you know donate a million
dollars six kids you follow through
which the program started in Cleveland
the way before every guys in New York
it's like a second second to backs like
page seven but this right here is page
one in six so and I think that's what
happened they look like people that
appreciated especially those kids one of
the kids Michael gundar's he was a hair
designer all that Nestle for the past
four years Wow and now he started his
own company man so I'm so proud of them
and that's why I said I don't I don't
want to have done it any other way like
I wish you know you say you wish you
could take things back but things lead
you down different paths like yeah I
wish I could stay with the Browns for
twelve years and made nine Pro Bowls and
never went to the playoffs or I could
say hey I got more touchdowns in the
season and Jim Brown has meanwhile I got
traded to the Jets and made two AFC
championships and they've only been to a
total of four and I'm a part of two of
them so yeah it is
you take everything with a grain of salt
things that these are fun I did it my
way right I have to ask you is your
favorite I grew up a Jets fan so like
your touchdown against the Patriots is
that your favorite NFL memory yes
after you carried out the Dennis burgers
each piece of my I was able to get a
chance to know him a lot that season
yeah I spoke to us a bunch of times and
I was there for the whole playoff run he
was mine just a great guy he's so much
fun I remember actually when I came back
from Team after getting you uh and I
came back and talked to him and he just
was she just was as good a good person
as you could be he say hey I understand
he said at the end of the day team's
first just get back team balls don't
worry about it
you're human he punched me in the
stomach a little bit Stacy that hurt
right but uh yeah that was a great
moment cuz you know I had a lot riding
on game I feel like even though we were
just great
like if you look at our loss with the
exception of the butt-kicking that
Patriots put on us and I was a week week
week 11 where they beat us 49 to 3
outside of that we should have been
undefeated lose about 1:00 to Green Bay
lose by 3 to Baltimore and some fluke
lose by 2 so I can't remember who else
but anyway that was my moment because we
proved the dollars long so we couldn't
beat the Patriots Peschel e mark
couldn't be Brady although they don't
play against each other house never
understood that we beat these guys in
the playoffs you know we're carrying the
momentum we didn't win a division we
beat all the distractions that have
happened throughout the year everything
that I mean we beat those distractions
and we took a tool in Gillette Stadium
of all places they don't lose at home in
the playoff
never never they don't lose at home I
think I think Tom has two losses in the
playoffs ever or maybe one I'm sure it's
2 or 1 and we're one of them so that was
that was in that moment that that play
kind of got it started like we were we
were you know stubborn art so it was a
back and forth seesaw kind of sorta I
don't know the exact score when I scored
but that players have played in kind of
catapulted us into the second half of
his right beforehand terribly and so
after that we came out just renewed man
we were we were ready man they're ready
and it's awesome again people check out
the book came out September 10th it's
called Braylon ed we're doing it my way
my outspoken life as a Michigan
Wolverine NFL receiver and beyond I
can't wait to get my hands on it because
if it's anything like this conversation
it's gonna be a lot of fun dude thank
you so much for hanging out with us
tonight we definitely appreciate your
time appreciate you dude that is our
show thank you to Braylon Edwards make
sure you check out his book I'm actually
I'm gonna download it read it on the
plane tomorrow morning from ello and
counter guys we will be again Jordans
big tin pub 1600 people getting drunk in
the beer garden makes seventy degrees
I'm gonna be in a hoodie you aren't a
hoodie we'll see how long it stays on
Connors not because those arms no
because you don't cover those arms I
mean look at the
as on today babies breathe that's what
Bill Belichick hoodie buddy this is I
didn't cut it myself don't like good old
bill you need to I'm I really want to
get us do you know and have you cut the
sleeves off let's - I'll do it
let's do it let's do it I might be
rocking a Minshew mustache when we get
there Saturday it's gonna be a lot of
fun from 8:00 until whatever we're gonna
be there so is it activity I'm gonna
koozie come hang out Regent Street is
gonna be poppin go badgers safe travels
to Connor we'll see you all Monday
morning from Wisconsin